der auftritt von angela merkel nach
ihrem ausscheiden aus dem kanzleramt im
gespräch mit alexander osang stellt sich
die ehemalige bundeskanzlerin erstmals
den herausfordernden fragen unserer
gegenwart direkt im anschluss diskutiert
die phoenix runde über das thema die
vertrauensfrage was muss politik heute
leisten angela merkel im gespräch
live aus dem berliner ensemble heute 20
uhr bei phoenix
der kanzler im baltikum scholz
verspricht unterstützung
extremismus in deutschland der
verfassungsschutzbericht und merkel im
gespräch
der erste öffentliche auftritt der ex-
kanzlerin das sind unsere themen in
phoenix den tag um 23 uhr
für die tiere in der wildnis geht es tag
für tag um alles oder nichts um über
leben oder sterben
jede art hat im laufe der evolution
besondere körperliche fähigkeiten oder
geschickte strategien entwickelt um
ihren eigenen fortbestand sichern zu
können selbst in extremsten lebensräumen
wildes überleben die nächsten beiden
folgen morgen ab 20 15 bei phoenix
[Musik]
phoenix vor ort
also schön ist ja hier sind herzlich
willkommen
in diesem wunderbaren theater zu diesem
abend an dem die
ehemalige bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
zum ersten mal seit ihrem amtsantritt
endlich größeren wird ob ich jedenfalls
und
ja das motto dieses abends ist
was also ist mein land
das ist auch der titel eines schmalen
bandes des aufbau verlages nun dass in
der 3 reden der bundeskanzlerin aus der
aus ihrer amtszeit enthält
und aufbau hat mich gebeten mein name
ist alexander osang ich bin reporterin
spiegeln aufwarten mich gebeten durch
diesen abend zu führen die fragen zu
stellen vermutlich war ich angela merkel
den letzten 20 jahren immer mal wieder
versucht habe jetzt porträtieren
mit wechselndem erfolg zum schluss hat
sie ja gar nicht mit mir geredet umso
umso mehr freut mich dass wir heute
zusammen reden werden und ich möchte
ganz am anfang einen text vorlesen den
den ich im letzten jahr für den für den
spiegel geschrieben habe zu ihrem
abschied zumindest teile des textes bei
frau merkel wartet er da hinten der
heißt
die auflösung beschreibt ein bisschen
unser feld ist damit sich nicht noch was
erhältlich machen
als mich der spiegel zum ersten mal bat
ein porträt bei angela merkel zu
schreiben lebt in new york
es war im januar 2000 ich weiß seit vier
monaten bei den spiegel und traute mich
nicht nein zu sagen sie hatten mich
gekauft damit ich in den osten erklären
ich allerdings mal gekommen da sind wir
ein leben in new york bezahlen konnten
ich wollte in den westen oder im
nächsten es raus aus dem osten es war
ein missverständnis und ich hatte noch
nicht die kraft das aufzuklären ich
reiße also aus dem spiegel büro in der
first avenue direkt zum kreisparteitag
der cdu nach krim
das liegt in vorpommern
er ist befanden sich viele westdeutsche
journalisten im schlepptau angela
merkels die gerade zur
parteivorsitzenden nominiert worden war
die beiden aufsteigender stern sie
führte die cdu in die zukunft eine
erfolgreiche ehrgeizige postlerin schon
das ist eine art wunder
es war matschig in vorpommern die
journalistinnen die angela merkel
begleiteten hüpften durch pfützen ich
bin erstmal zurück und redet mit einem
imker aus gewinnen der mehr erklärte
dass das glas honig dass er angela
merkel gerade geschenkt hat auf keinen
fall als eine parteispende mist zu
verstehen sei der knöpfe keine
erwartungen an den honig das war mehr
näher als wir angela merkel im laufe
meiner recherchen erlaubte ein paar tage
später gewährte sie mir ein einstündiges
interview in berlin bei dem sie vor
allem mich reden ließ sie fragte nicht
wie es in new york so sei und ich redete
und redete
als die stunde vorbei war stand sie auf
und ließ mich setzen
ich bin wieder auf guten weg merkel
gerade
ich habe mich dann ausführlich mit ihrem
vater und erhalten auch einen mann den
sie zurückgelassen hatte und der nicht
aufhören konnte zu reden anschließend
flog nach new york entsteht mein erstes
spiegel vorträgen
ein paar wochen später wurde ich von
dort ist er narrt überraschungsgast zu
einer sendung im bayerischen rundfunk
zugeschaltet bei der es um angela merkel
ging sie sagt im studio ich saß in
meiner küche und bürgern und hörte wie
der moderator die parteivorsitzende auch
das porträt im spiegel sprach sie sagt
er der hat ja nur aus meinem vater
rausgeholt dass ich
sie wusste nicht dass ich mit hörte und
fiel mir trotzdem nicht den rücken ich
fand das anständig und habe erst später
begriffen dass sich womöglich um ein
vergiftetes lob an die eltern soweit ich
weiß hat danach kaum noch mal jemanden
der journalist mit ihrem vater geredet
leute aus ihrem beruflichen umfeld von
denen es hieß design nicht loyal lösten
sich auf das reden immer nur dieselben
menschen die sich inzwischen in großer
entfernung zu ihr befinden man weiß
nicht genau ob sie sich an angela merkel
erinnern oder nur noch in die
geschichten die sie einst von mir
erzählt haben
vor vier jahren im letzten wahlkampf
probierte ich noch einmal ein porträt
angela merkel braucht ihrer tour durch
verschiedene ostseebäder sie flog mit
dem helikopter ich versuchte mit einem
mietwagen hinterher zu kommen
gespielten hase und igel ich war der
hase läuft war sie gerade wieder weg
wenn ich ankam ich interviewte leute
ihre bühne abbauten sie redete kein wort
mit mir
beim stop im ostseebad zingst aber traf
ich ein ehepaar aus vorpommern das der
kanzlerin einen großen bernstein
geschenkt hatte ich ließ also angela
merkel laufen und liegt bei den paar ich
begleitete sie nach hause ich fühle mit
ihnen zu der stelle an einer windigen
ostsee bucht muss ich einen stein
gefunden hatten ich versuche
herauszufinden warum sie die frau so
liebten deren partei eigentlich
überhaupt nicht ihre interessen vertrat
am ende fragte ich den
regierungssprecher was angela merkel mit
dem bernstein gemacht habe
er liege auf einem tisch steht mir
steffen seibert aber ich einen tisch
denn fragte ich
keine antwort
vor drei jahren
bei einem staatsbesuch in israel wo ich
inzwischen lebte
richtet sie noch einmal das wort dann
nicht sie fragte was machen sie denn
hier
das war spätabends ein dutzend
journalisten wartet in einem kleinen
saal im king david hotel in jerusalem
auch im hintergrundgespräch sie war die
einzige die ein glas weißwein trank und
wirkte zwischen all den staatsmännischen
journalisten am untersten wenn ich in
der nacht einen trinken gegangen wäre
dann am liebsten mit ihr in der fremde
land man sich oft besser kennen und
angela merkel schien sich auf jedes
abenteuer zu freuen
kürzlich habe ich eine dokumentation
über die reihe kanzlerkandidaten
baerbock laschet und scholz in der ard
gesehen sie zeigt olaf scholz beim
rudern annalena baerbock ben becker und
armin laschet füllt ein fußball
totenschein aus
zwischendurch spricht angela merkel aus
dem off kommentare zum regieren wie gott
man sieht sie nicht man sieht nur das
kanzleramt
durch die großen abschieds geschichten
der kanzlerin läuft das altbekannte
personal der angela merkel show die
große deutsche sitcom für jede episode
gibt es den entsprechenden cast neulich
im zeitmagazin ging es um angela merkel
dass frau die autorin schreiben dass
angela merkel individualismus als
eigentliche lebensformen betrachtet auch
weil eine ddr so verachtet wurde sie
argumentieren die im kollektiv wenn das
stimmt weiß ich warum ich sie mag ich
kenne den unwillen für andere zu
sprechen die scheu vom blick von der
geschlossenheit von gemeinsam abstimmen
vom kollektiven freundschaft rufen auf
dem appellplatz die fehlende ehrfurcht
vor der großen rede der vision all das
ist zumindest bei mir im osten
entstanden ich habe ganz am anfang ihrer
karriere beobachtet wie sich angela
merkel klammern in ost politiker hinzu
sie wollte keine nische wie sie keine
vision wollte sie hat sich den
ostdeutschen und den westdeutschen
erwartet an ihr leben soweit entzogen
dass sie am ende gar nicht mehr zu
erkennen war
manche werden schwarz haft am ende ihrer
karriere sie rote stellen
sich angela merkel das erste mal traf
zog sie als neu gewählte cdu
generalsekretärin und adenauer haus das
war noch in bonn sie ließ gerade die
möbel ihres vorgängers peter hintze
heraustragen männer möbel wie sie sagte
ich mag kein schwarzes leder sagte sie
mir damals ich würde niemanden
einschüchtern ich mag diesen leder
geruch nicht heute fast 25 jahren klingt
das was haben sie mir da ein höchst
intimes geständnis gemacht vor kurzem
sagte sie zur katastrophalen situation
in afghanistan
wir müssen unsere ziele künftig kleiner
setzen
konfuzius verletzt das kanzleramt
hat es mich sicher spiegel das letzte
mal bat ein porträt von angela merkel zu
schreiben sagte ich nein ich war jetzt
20 jahre da und hat er den mut ich habe
auch nicht das gefühl irgendetwas neues
von ihr erfahren zu können wenn ich eine
einzige frage an kanzlerin frei hatte
würde ich sie fragen wie geht es ihnen
eigentlich
angela merkel wollte nie dass
irgendjemand anderes dieser porträts das
kanzleramt von ihr malt sie hat sich vor
meinen augen in ein verwandelter gemälde
wie alle anderen zeugen ihrer geschichte
hat nun muss sie sich aufgelöst
vielen dank
die gute nachricht ist dass nach dieser
auflösung angela merkel jetzt hinter
diesem vorhaben quartett die bürgerin
angela merkel mit der ich freue mich
sehr hoffentlich offener als zu ihren
amtszeiten über ihre amtszeiten sprechen
kann darüber das letzte jahr das ja auch
eine halbe jahren nach iran nach ihrem
amtsjahr auch relativ ereignisreich war
freue mich also auch frau angela merkel
eine kanzlerin die sie so immer bleiben
hallo
[Applaus]
ich weiß war ganz schön lang die bitter
weil es war ganz schön lang
[Musik]
noch länger
aber jetzt möchte gelinge darüber geht
sie eigentlich
die frage die eigentlich damals schon
stellen würde ja ich habe davon gelesen
also heute geht es mir persönlich sehr
gut
und ich freue mich auch dass ich ja an
diesem ort sein kann
insgesamt ist natürlich hatte ich mir
natürlich die zeit nach meiner amtszeit
anders vorgestellt
und mit dem 24 februar ist einfach eine
zäsur in entstanden und die beschäftigt
mich natürlich auch sehr aber wenn sie
nach dem persönlichen fragen ich habe
freiwillig aufgehört
als bundeskanzlerin das ist auch ein
schönes gefühl und
ich habe mir dann ein paar andere dinge
vorgenommen zu tun ist auch ein schönes
gefühl aber ich bleibe natürlich auch
ein politischer mensch und deshalb bin
ich in diesen tagen so wie viele viele
andere auch manchmal bedrückt es läuft
wird trotzdem gern noch mal die zeit was
ich natürlich absolut bewegt ist wie
kommt man eigentlich die letzten bilder
die ich von ihnen gesehen habe waren da
im bendlerblock ziemlich kalt es liebt
es lief du hast den farbfilm vergessen
und für mich ist das rote rosen regnen
und ich haben sie mal gefragt wie kommt
man aus dieser situation runter die
schafft man das wieder normales leben zu
leben ich habe gehört sie nennen das aus
lüften und sie haben an der ostsee aus
gelüftet
wie funktioniert das
naja also die ist es ja am morgen ist es
genau ein halbes jahr her seit ich die
letzten bilder familie im kanzleramt
gesehen habe da ist nämlich roland olaf
scholz eingezogen und dann habe ich mich
auf diese zeit gefreut und habe ja auch
eine menge mehr vorgenommen das ging im
grunde zwei richtungen sag ich jetzt mal
mehr bewegung weil das war wirklich zu
kurz gekommen und dafür ist die ostsee
natürlich wunderbar
und zwei
sachen lesen zu denen ich nicht gekommen
bin ich habe immer mal kurze bücher
gelesen aber oder bücher angefangen zu
lesen aber so ein richtiges dickes buch
mal zu lesen das war schön ich hab das
feld was natürlich sie alle längst
kennen des hörbuchs mir ein bisschen
erarbeitet da
das schöne ist dass man sich da nicht
ganz so konzentrieren muss wie beim
lesen finde ich habe gehört sie an
shakespeare
relativ herauszuarbeiten
danach nord und karlsruhe länge
genau aber das aber das ist richtig
meinte ich habe also mir ist was ich ja
auch nicht wusste ist ich finde ganz
alleine an die ostsee gefahren und ich
dachte ich muss das auch ein bisschen
üppiger machen und habe dort im grunde
fünf wochen verbracht und ich wusste
nämlich ganz genau was mir langweilig
wird und da erstaunlicherweise ist es
mir nicht langweilig geworden sondern
ich habe
den tag einfach richtig gut um bekommen
und um bekommen wir jetzt ein bisschen
komisch an aber ich wusste er gar nicht
mehr wie es ist ich habe 30 jahre
politik gemacht und hatte immer termine
termine termine und war eigentlich sehr
sehr froh und glaube seitdem dass ich
mit diesen neuen lebensabschnitt sehr
gut
zurecht kommen und auch sehr glücklich
sein kann
haben sie dann ich habe in dem buch von
meiner kollegin hat den räumen diesen
dass sie
sie sagen uns stimmt oder nicht
überhaupt eine kamel kapazität verfügen
das heißt sie können schlaf speichern
und und
auch nach schlafen das heißt sie haben
war wie immer behauptet ich habe
inzwischen
reihe von medizinern gelesen die gesagt
haben es quatsch so was kann man nicht
ernst nehmen weil ich keine fachfrau bin
aber ich glaube über kurze zeit kann man
das ich glaube von gültiges anspruchs
eine zeitlang können schlafen und essen
füreinander einstehen das gehört ja dann
auch zu den ungewohnte also nicht guten
gewohnheiten dass man dann spätabends
noch ist und solche sachen macht also
ein bisschen kann man schon aus pendeln
die ressourcen aber über ganz lange zeit
geht das natürlich auch nicht aber die
alle waren ja die ganze welt war besorgt
über sozusagen diese zittern fälle die
sie hatten
nicht immer ansprechen überhaupt hatten
die mit erschöpfung zu tun oder ich habe
jetzt mal der erste war übrigens
dezember weiter das ist die letzte
chance bekam also ich glaube es hatte
mit zwei dingen zu tun einmal war ich
glaube ich schon sehr erschöpft nach dem
tod meiner mutter das hat mich doch mehr
in anspruch genommen als ich dachte
zweiten dings sondern auch mit wenig
trinken zusammen und zum schluss war es
dann eigentlich auch schon so eine art
angst wenn überhaupt wieder so eine
situation auftrat und dann bin ich
eigentlich damit sehr sehr gut zu rande
gekommen als ich dann stuhl auf das
podest gestellt habe und die national
dem sitzen
abgenommen habe und das ging auch und
das hat mir dann gut getan ist ja auch
ziemlich ein schlechtes szenario immer
diese
einmal die hand schreiben diese militär
unter diese teleobjektive eingerichtet
ist natürlich schon offensichtlich doch
eine belastung die in einem steckt das
gehört mir gut vorstellen gerade
wie haben sie sich denn als sie als sie
da nahost iran das erstmal noch mal die
so aussehen was so toll an ostsee
natürlich mit an bord sich zum beispiel
müssen ertragen
also das ist einfach dass ich mich da
besser auskenne das war auch in meinem
ehemaligen wahl also warum er mehr weil
für mich mehr etwas sehr beruhigendes
hat weil ich besser im sommer an
deutschen mehreren nicht auftauche weil
ich dachte mich besonders vier uhr habe
aber im winter
kann man sagen versendet sich das kapuze
auf und nicht so viele wanderer und ins
dann regnet und so ein bisschen schnee
regen ist es leichter zweitens war die
vorteil dass sie mir etwa auskenne in
der umgebung wenn alles ungewohnt ist
also ich könnte auch die nordsee
vorstellen vom prinzip her aber das war
eben meinen wahlkreis und da kenne ich
mich aus und drittens weil die leute
dort an mich gewöhnt sind sind sie auch
sehr schweigsam und
es konnten nein
das war eigentlich der mine baar kreis
war meine lebensversicherung meine
politische lebensversicherung für mich
weil ich dort ein ungefiltertes das
urteil bekommen habe über das was aber
ein ziemlich ungefiltertes urteil über
das was den menschen gedacht haben weil
wir auch durchaus kontrovers sprechen
konnten aber nie was in der zeitung
stand und mich haben dort heute scheint
auch leute begrüßung sagt wir wissen
alle dass sie da sind aber niemand hat
es einer zeitung verraten und das muss
man erst mal in deutschland finden haben
sie perfekten wahlkreis hatte ich ja
absolut darum wird ja sowieso nicht
super viel redet wie haben sie sich dann
die haben die richtung eigentlich
informiert also während der zeit in der
ostsee und dann später wahrscheinlich
auch in europa markt ich glaube ja auch
diese cent würden sie haben ja haben sie
mir mal irgendwann erzählt oder
irgendjemand aus ihrem umfeld der es mir
nicht erzählen dürfen erzählte sie ganz
viele
nachrichten auf ihr handy zum beispiel
bekommen haben die mit ihrem mann mit
ihrer arbeit zu tun haben und die
entfernung von sozusagen von dieser
nachrichtenlage sie wollten ja immer vor
der lage sein die sie sagt
dass wir die findet bei mir nicht ganz
so hart statt weil ich ja durch meinen
alt kanzlerin büro jetzt noch zugang zu
informationen aber auch zur
agenturmeldungen oder spiegel online was
schönes für sie zu sagen oder
andere zeitungen ich kann mich jetzt
nicht alle aufzählen es war keine
werbung also ich habe mich nicht
abgeschnitten gefühlt von den
informationen ich kann mir ja auch
zeitung kaufen und die lesen ich lese
auszeit seite
bilden zum beispiel firma darum sollte
man die ostsee-zeitung wir uns zumindest
den lokalteil
auf jeden fall
sturmschäden
skandale und was so alles gibt also das
ist schon besser man weiß das aber
nein spaß beiseite ich war ja immer auch
jemand der wenn immer die zeit erlaubte
gerne zeitungen gelesen hat in ihren
verschiedenen teilen und auch sehr sehr
viele informationen aus zeitungen
genommen also ich denke wenn man die
summe aller überregionalen zeitungen in
deutschland nimmt dann ist man schon
recht gut informiert das ist ein
privileg
wo habe ich einen ausweis wo haben sie
denn oder wie haben sie denn
erfahren oder verfolgt das portieren wir
nähern uns den 24
seine truppen da zusammen zogen sie ist
in der tagesschau oder werden sie da
kann sie danach kann ein das habe ich ja
noch während meiner amtszeit verfolgen
also ich war ich denke spätestens beim g
20 gipfel in rom ende oktober hatten ja
die dienste der vereinigten staaten
schon hinweise auf und seitdem haben wir
darüber sehr viel gesprochen und ich
hatte dann auch noch meinen letzten
amtstagen
wir haben mit vielen in europa darüber
geredet also das war schon eine
brenzlige situation und dann war ja noch
die bundespräsidentenwahl vorher und da
war das ja auch schon ganz
offensichtlich und dann der habe ich ja
auch teilgenommen und da konnte ich mich
auch nochmal kurz mit verschiedenen
leuten austauschen also das war dann
schon klar dass man das sehr sehr ernst
nehmen muss was da
stattfand und dann habe ich natürlich
den besuch von olaf scholz noch in
moskau verfolgt und die puma
anstrengungen dort den republiken da die
vermeintlichen separatisten du kannst
nur hans und don jetzt dass sie du mal
den wunsch hat dass die selbstständig
werden oder sogar ja und das habe ich
also schon alles minutiös verfolgt und
mir war schon klar dass da etwas nicht
gutes passiert im übrigen hatte ich auch
schon monate meiner letzten amtszeit
meines letzten amtsjahres mitbekommen
dass auf dem gebiet des minsk abkommens
eigentlich nichts mehr lief im normandie
format und das präsident putin damit im
grunde abgeschlossen hatte und das war
nicht gut weil das war sozusagen der
einzige haken den dennoch in der hand
hatten um überhaupt über diese situation
im dort was zu sprechen also dass da die
entwicklung nicht gut weil ich war ja
dann noch mal zum abschiedsbesuch in
moskau auch da ist mir das noch mal klar
geworden und da kann man eigentlich auch
überhaupt nicht mehr weiter
weil sie gerade mensch muss sagen dass
ich mir was ich mich natürlich frage ist
wenn man nach ließ zum beispiel welche
aktivitäten sie entwickelt haben im
februar
2015 wo sie innerhalb von fünf tagen
hatte mal zusammengerechnet irgendwie in
washington waren bei obama sie waren
denn sie waren hier ausschenken sie
waren sie waren in moskau bei putin die
waren zwischendurch immer in berlin
sogar auf der sicherheitskonferenz und
sind dann nach mainz geflogen
wie fühlt man sich dann wenn man dann
und natürlich haben sie das verfolgt
oder die nachrichtendienste und trotzdem
schien es ja sozusagen vor dem 24 eine
art countdown zu geben es wurden
sozusagen es wurde eher dramatischer von
tag zu tag wenn man
daran hat so weit weg ist wenn man im
fischland sitzt oder oder in der
uckermark und
könnte sich da ohnmächtig oder oder ist
es eher um eine art von
von erleichterung
also ich hab mich ich habe ich in diesen
tagen besonders
erfreut ist der falsche ausdruck aber
ich habe mich war mit mir im reinen
darüber dass der regierung
übergangsweise
oft gesagt worden beim g20-treffen olaf
scholz schon immer mit dabei wenn man
die staats und regierungschefs getroffen
hat und als wir dann zum beispiel eben
auch mit präsident beiden gesprochen
habe war ja auch dabei hat also
sozusagen in diesem übergang immer auch
alle informationen gehabt und da ich
diesen regierungs übergangsjahr für
gelungen sagen wir mal im demokratischen
sinne gehalten habe habe ich gewusst wir
haben zu einander vertrauen wenn jemand
von mir etwas wissen würde ich jederzeit
antwort geben aber ich hatte auch
vertrauen in die die agiert haben und
das macht die sache in aller kümmern ist
und beklommenheit natürlich einfacher
was ich mich natürlich gefragt habe ist
was hat man vielleicht versäumt hätte
man noch mehr tun können um eine solche
tragik ich halte diesen diese situation
jetzt schon für eine große tragik hätte
man das verhindern können und
dass deshalb stellt man sich daher
stelle ich mir natürlich immer wieder
diesen fragen aber ich mache mir gar
nicht vorstellen ich hätte kein
vertrauen in die jetzige bundesregierung
das wäre für mich sehr sehr beklemmend
aber so kann man die konnte ich die
macht gut abgeben und sagen jetzt sind
eben andere daran und die müssen das
jetzt machen das ist ein ich kann ja an
die schwer das ist ja so ist es mir
gegangen also sie hatten nicht das
bedürfnis jetzt leute anzurufen sind
hier anrufen worden
hätte ich groß drüber sprechen
dass es funktioniert wenn es sein soll
sowie für sage nicht nein aber auch
nicht so dass jeden tag fünf gespräche
führe aber sie können nicht sagen wer da
angerufen hat das möchte ich jetzt nicht
genau also urlaubsort hat ja schon hat
ja schon gesagt dass sie miteinander
gesprochen haben genau darüber
[Musik]
schauen sie
die
die frage
ist jetzt einfach dass dort menschen am
werk sind mit der neuen bundesregierung
die kennen ja ist nicht auch keine
newcomer die kennen die gegebenheiten
und wenn jetzt etwas passieren würde das
ist das was mich beruhigt wo ich sagen
das gibt die vollkommen falsche richtung
dann kann ich sehr viel anrufen das
musste ich aber noch nicht
sie haben kurz erwähnt dass das sie sich
natürlich gefragt haben was man hätte
machen können wo ihre versäumnisse lang
was ist da was kommt als erstes naja was
man hätte machen können mussten ja nicht
immer versäumnisse seien aber weil wir
sind jetzt immer so schnell dabei ich
habe mich versucht noch mal wieder in
die zeiten auch zu versetzen und bei
näherer betrachtung
manchen tag in dem ich so darüber
nachgedacht habe hatte ich ihn erneut
dass ich mich eigentlich in meiner
ganzen kasseler schafft ununterbrochen
mit den fragen die aus dem zerfall der
sowjetunion und den daraus entstehenden
konstellation entstanden sind das waren
georgien und ukraine und das ist
natürlich immer wieder auch die sorge
des baltikums das ist moldawien das ist
armenien und aserbaidschan
und dann ist mir noch mal so bewusst
geworden im grunde kann man sagen als
ich anfang 2007 präsident putin in
sotschi besucht habe da war hatte
deutschland die eu ratspräsidentschaft
in der europäischen union das war der
berühmte besuch mit dem hund und dort
haben wir zum ersten mal das
ausgetauscht dass er ja auch öffentlich
gesagt hat dass der kreis jetzt auch
sagen dass für ihn der zerfall der
sowjetunion die schlimmste sache des 20
jahrhunderts war und ich habe ihm gesagt
beste für mich ist wahr dass der
glücksumstand meines lebens und so
konnte ich eben in die freiheit und dann
auch das machen dass mir spaß und freude
macht und da war schon ganz klar dass da
ein grosser distanz ist und dieser
distanz hat sich immerfort entwickelt
und es ist nicht gelungen in all diesen
jahren
sozusagen den kalten krieg wirklich zu
wenden wenn man es mal heute hart auf
hart sondern es ist immer bei all
unserem glück und bei dem glück der
europäischen einigung und der vielen
ländern die aus den osteuropa und
mitteleuropa dazu kommen könnten ist
immer dieser punkt russland geblieben
und ich teile nicht die meinung von
herrn putin um das ganz klar zu sagen
aber es ist eben auch nicht gelungen
eine sicherheitsarchitektur zu schaffen
die dieses hier hätte verhindern können
und darüber muss man schon nachdenken
aber das wäre ja dann auch historiker
noch tun klar ist und das will ich hier
nun mal sagen weil damit camps
verständnis entsteht dieser überfall auf
die ukraine wir haben 24 februar
stattgefunden hat findet keinerlei
rechtfertigung dass ein brutaler das
völkerrecht missachtet überfall für den
es keine entschuldigung gibt
[Applaus]
und haben sie trotzdem einen augenblick
daran gedacht hier griff 2007 und auf
den hund und so kann man nur zu sprechen
dass
das er gewartet hat dass er gerade sie
weg sind
also ich sag mal so es gab sicherlich
eine ganze menge von dingen die auch er
betrachtet hat und dass es
eine sache liegt mir noch immer ein
bisschen schwer im magen dass es einfach
das im juni 2021 hat sich präsident
biden mit putin getroffen
und ich war der meinung damals mit dem
handel makro man müsste versuchen auch
von europäischer seite ihn in einen
dialog zu bekommen weil ich schon auch
ein bisschen gespürt habe dass das mit
dienst nicht gut läuft und
darüber gab es dann zum schluss in der
europäischen union keine einigung
und da habe ich so gedacht na ja du bist
eben auch jetzt jeder weiß dass du weg
bist und sagen wir mal jahre vorher
hätte ich das vielleicht noch
durchgeboxt so es gab dann verschiedene
dinge die eine rolle spielen könnten das
weiß ich aber auch nicht in frankreich
waren in deutschland wahlen der
überstürzter abzug aus afghanistan das
alles hat die korona pandemie der
frühere chef des senders durch dieses
opposition sein dass in russland hat zum
beispiel gesagt das ipad ohne auch eine
sehr großen einfluss auf diese dinge
hatte der praktisch zwei jahre lang kaum
uns gesehen haben keine direkte
konfrontation haben und bot in bayern
und auch in besonderer weise
sozusagen man sie uns kennt ja noch die
langen tische und die tests und heute
keinen sehen war beim g20 treffen
persönlich dabei also auch sehr sehr
vorsichtig aber
das nutzt alles nichts das kann man
sagen kann sein kann nicht sein dass
eine reine spekulation das was passiert
ist ist aus meiner sicht
nicht also nicht nicht nur nicht
akzeptabel sondern eben einfach von
russland seite ein großer fehler
absolut und ein 1 1 jetzt lassen wir bei
der subjektiven bewertung weg ist ein
objektiver bruch aller völkerrechtlichen
regelungen und all dessen was uns in
europa überhaupt in frieden
zusammenleben lässt wenn wir anfangen
durch die jahrhunderte zu gehen und
sagen welches stück territorium gehört
wem dann haben wir nur noch krieg das
geht auf gar keinen fall
und trotzdem muss ich bei ihnen bleiben
weiß es ist jemand der
der sich ja schon
der so lange in den politischen geschäft
das die
sie haben wenn ich das richtig
verstanden habe
ja im prinzip dieser amtszeit schon dran
gehängt weil sie die welt nicht um es
ein bisschen grob zusagen nicht mehr
präsident trump alleine lassen wollten
die westliche welt
womöglich hatte obama sich auch darum
gebeten weiß ich nicht aber in jedem
fall war die welt
der romantik
war die welt
im relativ schlechten zustand autokraten
populisten einfacher neben präsent war
sie sieht sie haben es noch mal gemacht
und und und dass sie zurücktraten
wahnbek aber aber es gab
putin ist sozusagen
entfesselt worden irgendwie in gewisser
weise und und die frage für mich ist
gibt es denn einen richtigen zeitpunkt
um um zurückzutreten ich sagte ja schon
dass ich volles vertrauen in die jetzige
politische führung habe trotzdem sollte
die eben keine demokratischen wahlen
kennen die in russland zum beispiel die
für die sind das dann natürlich trotzdem
einschnitte das ist ja klar aber
ich musste jetzt aufhören das ist
vollkommen klar man ich hätte nach zwölf
jahren aufhören können manche haben
gesagt dass wir auch der richtige
zeitpunkt gewesen ich habe mich dann
ziemlich gequält ich habe es noch mal
gemacht auch weil ich damals fand dass
das nicht so richtig gut ist ich das gab
war ja die zeit der flüchtlingspolitik
und als so viele menschen zu uns kamen
und dann war sozusagen 2016 das
einigermaßen sag ich mal auch durch das
eu türkei abkommen wieder in einem
bestimmten gleichgewicht und dann 2017
wenn die menschen darüber entscheiden
können wie fanden sie das jetzt dann
sage ich einfach so das war's das fand
ich nicht so gut also für mich nicht die
richtigen zeitpunkt nach langem lange
überlegen danach war es ja nun
vollkommen klar das hat ja einen
gewissen anachronistischen ein anschlag
a13 schlag 16 jahre ist für die heutige
zeit wirklich lange und deshalb musste
innenpolitisch auf jeden fall eine neue
regierung her das hat man an allen ecken
und enden gespürt ich hätte mir
natürlich gewünscht das ist eine cdu
geführte regierung aber es war
demokratische wahl und insofern ist es
jetzt die regierung die es ist und in
die habe ich außenpolitisch vertrauen
dadurch ist das besser aber natürlich
ist jetzt wird ja was mich manchmal
etwas traurig macht ist es ist ja gar
nicht so ganz einfach sich in die jahre
der bukarest nato gipfel 2008 warum es
die entscheidung zu gefallen minsk
abkommen wenn ich da so im internet lese
ja es sozusagen in der notsituation für
die ukraine entstanden und eigentlich
kein faires abkommen und da finde ich
müssen wir jetzt schon aufpassen dass
wir nicht nur noch schwarz und weiß
sehen sondern dass wir uns wirklich noch
mal die umstände angucken und ich bin im
rückblick wenn ich über alles um ihre
eigentlich froh dass ich mir nicht
vorwerfen muss ich habe es zu wenig
versucht mit ein solches ereignis wie es
jetzt stattgefunden hat zu verhindern
sondern ich habe es glücklicherweise
ausreichend versucht
mit dem französischen jeweiligen
französischen präsidenten zusammen und
das gibt mir jedenfalls eine gewisse
beruhigung ich würde mich sehr schlecht
fühlen wenn man gesagt hat auch mit dem
man braucht gar nicht zu reden der
sowieso jemand ich meine wir reden hier
über russland russland ist die
zweitgrößte atommacht der welt russland
ist territorial ein riesen gebilde von
asien bis europa und auch wenn man den
europäischen teil nimmt eines der
größten länder europas und die bleiben
existieren also es ist eine große trauer
das gelungen ist aber ich mache mir
jetzt keine vorwürfe dass ich es
versucht habe ganz kurzer exkurs nach
bukarest
da gab es ja zumindest zu einer den
wunsch der amerikaner
für so eine vorstufe der der
nato-mitglieder architektin anja heißt
es action points
für
für auch für die ukraine und da waren
sie extrem dagegen ja
warum
ja es ging um die ukraine und das ging
um georgien und ich hatte
also erstens bei betrachtung der ukraine
war die ukraine endlich die die wir von
heute kennen es war eine ukraine in der
es politisch sehr sehr gespalten war
zwischen janukowitsch und juschtschenko
und selbst die reformkräfte timoschenko
und juschtschenko haben sich nicht
besonders gut vertragen das heißt es war
kein innerlich demokratisch gefestigt
das land und wenn man ein land in eine
nato aufnimmt und der membership action
plan ist die klare vorstufe dazu dann
muss man wissen dass
wir dann auch bereit sind ein solches
land wirklich zu verteidigen wenn es
einen angriff gibt zweitens weil ich mir
sehr sicher und deshalb fand ich dass
die ukraine ihre demokratischen weg
weitergehen muss sehr sicher dass putin
das nicht wird einfach geschehen lassen
das war für ihn allein effektive und
eine kriegserklärung
und jetzt kann man ja sagen das kann ich
nicht ich teil da überhaupt nichts ich
dass er den ganzen westen als seinen
feind ansieht dass er findet dass er
permanent gedemütigt wurde all das teile
ich überhaupt nicht aber ich habe
gewusst wer dachte und dass er das
genauso sieht und
es hat ja dann auch nur wenige monate
gedauert das in georgien dieser krieg
mit
im zusammenhang des interessieren und
asien ausgebrochen ist wo dann der
präsident sarkozy noch vermittelt hat
und es war vollkommen klar er wird es
auch in der ukraine nicht geschehen
lassen weil wir ja schon wussten dass er
in moldawien transnistrien auch sein
fall geschaffen hat das im grunde
russland immer mit einem fuß in diesem
land ist und damit ist dann wieder
unmöglich macht dass dieses land sich
richtung westen mehr orientieren kann
und ich wollte das nicht weiter
provozieren und zweitens war die
entwicklung nicht gefestigt genug und da
muss man sich schon drauf verlassen und
drittens ehrlich gesagt das muss man ja
auch sagen
residenz selensky kämpft unglaublich
mutig gegen die korruption an aber
damals war dann war die ukraine schon
auch ein von oligarchen beherrschtes
land und das kann man nicht einfach
sagen die euch nehmen wir morgen in die
nato aus und ich deshalb weiter strikt
dagegen das ergebnis muss man sagen war
in zwei richtungen schwierig es gibt
interessantes buch von dem heutigen
cs-chef burns der war damals botschafter
in moskau und hat die ganzen dramatik
auch beschrieben hat auch genau in
seinem buch berg channel beschrieben wie
putin mit ihm gegenüber argumentiert hat
und es gab damals drei ereignisse die
putin eben sehr sehr kritisch gesehen
hat
unabhängigkeitserklärung des kosovos
raketenschirm dass präsident george bush
und der membership action plan der
ukraine so und jetzt
war ich eben der meinung ich möchte
diese
dieser eskalation
verhindert und man kann nicht von heute
auf morgen der nato beitreten präsident
selenz gehört ja neulich gesagt ja wenn
die ukraine mitglied der nato wäre
würden wir sie heute aktiv mit unseren
soldaten mit verteidigen aber das ist
ein prozess und in diesem prozess wusste
ich dass putin etwas tun wird was der
ukraine nicht gut tut und deshalb weiß
agiert das ergebnis war aber dann zum
schluss nein
georgen enttäuscht und um die nato nicht
vollkommen auseinander fallen zu lassen
weil alle osteuropäer dafür waren bei
präsident bush dafür waren wir dann
gesagt aber irgendwann kann sie auch
mitglied der nato werden damit war putin
enttäuscht und in alarmbereitschaft aber
das jetzt egal es rechtfertigt putins
heutiges tun nicht nur sagen das war
damals meine beweggründe
sie haben dann sie waren dann in
georgien und haben das auch gesagt sie
können irgendwann mitglied der nato
werden er ist war ja das community also
es war ja der kompromiss genau und es
ist ja auch schwer zu sagen das ist ja
was ihr könnt wir haben zwar einen
helsinki unterschrieben dass jedes land
sich seinen weg suchen kann aber leider
gilt das für euch nicht also das ist ja
auch nicht ganz einfach aber es gibt
eben dinge
man möchte ja eigentlich das oder ich
hätte gerne gewollt dass solches leid
erspart bleibt was jetzt über das
ukrainische volk kommt und auch georgien
ist ja seit nämlich weiter gekommen sind
dass sie nach asien das ist ja auch so
ein eingefrorener konflikt
wir haben darüber geredet ob es der
richtige zeitpunkt waren oder sie zurück
zu treten können gibt es eigentlich wenn
man so wieder anzutreten nicht wieder
anzutreten
für mich ist tot
gibt es denn eigentlich überhaupt wenn
man es so lange gemacht hat wenn man so
eine bedeutung und der welt hat darunter
außenpolitischen welt
kann man überhaupt auf
es liegt in der natur der demokratie
nicht dass man aufhört entweder man wird
irgendwann abgewählt oder man kommt
freiwillig zu dem entschluss aber
menschliches leben ist endlich und
politische verantwortung ist auch
endlich und ich finde mit 16 jahren habe
ich jetzt kein unter kontingent also
wenn ihr nach wenn ich jetzt nach vier
jahren gesagt hätte das war sehr
interessant und jetzt finde ich auch
dass ich jetzt auch mal die bühne
verlassen sollte das
habe ich hätte ich nicht gedacht und ist
es ja manchmal auch wichtig dass neue
gedanken reinkommen und ganz neue
impulse und auch neue konstellationen
und ich hab dann schon auch nach 16
jahren gemerkt wenn wenn ich so viele
konflikte durchgestanden hatte so viele
nächte durch verhandelt habe dass ich
vielleicht manchmal auch nicht mehr ganz
so kampfes freudig bin die acht jahre
vorher und für mich war es ganz klar
dass das der richtige zeitpunkt ist und
ich würde auch wenn ich mal frage was
macht der demokratie aus demokratie
macht aus dass immer bedingungen
geschaffen werden in der man in der
jeder der kandidiert auch gut wieder ab
oder jeder der namen besetzt auch gut
wieder abgewählt werden kann also länder
die das sehr schwer machen die sind mir
suspekt
ich meine
vielleicht meinen sie ja sie meinen
irgendwie habe ich so den eindruck sie
meinen naja nun hatte ich da so viel
auch erfahrung und jetzt ist das
eigentlich macht er das nicht verrückt
dass man jetzt nicht mehr am tisch sitzt
und nehmen aber dann ist sozusagen das
nicht nur siege
sondern dass die öffentlichkeit
irgendwie den eindruck hat dass sie es
gab in den letzten wochen immer wieder
also wunder politik polnische
ministerpräsident aber ob sie als kind
so sie sollen sich äußern sie sollen
was dazu sagen leitartikler
kommentatoren die früher einmal
gefordert haben sie sie sollten endlich
aufhören wollen sie jetzt wieder haben
und aber vor allem um sozusagen die die
die lage zu erklären da ist ja schon
eindruck entsteht ich glaube auch dass
wir beide ein bisschen dazu da sind und
diesen um diesem bedürfnis der
öffentlichkeit nachzugeben hier auf
dieser bühne machte gerne und ich auch
es gibt nichts gesteht gefühl dass man
glaubt man gehört sozusagen sie sind ja
jetzt wirklich bundeskanzlerin ag
gehört irgendwie der der öffentlichkeit
nein also das führt uns jetzt an ein
ganz bestimmt punkt es gibt ja
verschiedene aspekte die eine aspekt ist
dass die leute gesagt haben wohl wo ist
sie und jetzt ist eine zäsur passiert
etwas ganz außergewöhnliches und jetzt
wollen wir von ihr hören wie sieht sie
die vergangenen jahre damit wir auch
noch mal also gibt ja sehr viel kritik
auch und damit wir uns damit noch mal
auseinandersetzen können und dann kannst
du dir einfach abhauen und sich zu
diesen dingen nicht mehr äußern und das
wäre auch fatal weil ich natürlich über
jede dieser entscheidung unendlich lange
auch nachgedacht habe überlegt habe
viele entscheidungen sind nicht 100 zu
null sondern die sind 49 prozent zu 51
und ich weiß schon dass zum beispiel
dass minsk abkommen
nicht für die ukraine ein abkommen ist
was alle ihre interessen erfüllt aber es
hat damals ist ein abkommen was damals
in einer situation wo 6000 soldaten
drohten eingeschlossen zu werden weil
die walze wohl erstmal ein stück ruhe
reingebracht hat obwohl diese ruhe nie
so gut war wie wir das in dem abkommen
wollten und was ich manchmal jetzt
bedaure dass ich ganz offen dieses
abkommen ist von der eu
belobigt worden genehmigt begrüßt dieses
abkommen ist in eine un
sicherheitsratsresolution
eingeflossen hat damit völkerrechtlichen
charakter und dann nämlich heute um
gucke wie viele noch zu diesem abkommen
stehen da muss ich aber lange suchen ich
noch einen findet er die sache jetzt
schlecht verhandelt damals hat es ruhe
reingebracht und hat zb der ukraine auch
sehr viel zeit gegeben sieben jahre
nämlich sich zudem zu entwickeln was
heute ist und ich finde den sie den mut
und den light die leidenschaft mit denen
die für irland kämpfen und ja wirklich
so
beeindruckend und auch präsident
seelands gehen dass man davor die
allergrößte hochachtung haben kann so
jetzt kommt punkt 2 wer bin ich heute
und da bin ich manchmal schon ein
bisschen erschrocken ich bin
bundeskanzlerin a d ich bin keine ganz
normale bürgerin in dem sinne nicht dass
ich fast noch vorsichtiger sein muss zu
den heutigen aktuellen dingen was zu
sagen als jeder der von ihnen hier
herkommt war ja immerhin sagt merkt sagt
so und scholz hat aber gesagt und die
hart gesagt und dann hat man es steht
man wieder plötzlich voll im politischen
leben das ist nicht meine aufgabe ist
kommentar von der seitenlinie zu geben
die und trotzdem bin ich nicht neutral
in diesem konflikt so und jetzt ist
meine hoffnung
nach wie vor ich suche ja noch nach
meinem weg was ist eine bundeskanzlerin
die ich habe ein büro wie ich gelesen
habe auch ein sehr großes ich habe ein
schönes büro
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern und
ich finde eine bundeskanzlerin die ja
auch von den menschen gewählt wurde vier
mal die hat schon auch die aufgabe wenn
es gut laufen sollte noch ein bisschen
etwas für das land zu tun und wenn
gewünscht wird das land zu
repräsentieren aber eins haben mir auch
vorgenommen
dass ich mir auch ein bisschen meine
formate aussuchen kann deshalb bin ich
über dieses gespräch froh weil ich hatte
mit meinem team diskutiert was könnte
ich machen ich sehr viele einladungen
aber ich will jetzt nicht immer nur
wieder termine ab arbeiten wo mich
jemand einlädt sondern ich möchte auch
etwas machen was mir freude macht und
damit trotzdem etwas für das land sein
kann und wenn ich dann lese ja
jetzt keine journalisten schelde
betreiben aber wohl fühlt merkels leicht
sich zurück und macht jetzt nur noch
wohlfühlt amine da sag ich ja
zehn jahre und 16 jahre sind eine lange
zeit ist alles was von relevanz in
diesem lande war irgendwie an meinem
tisch vorbei und ich habe immer gesagt
ganz am schluss trage ich für alles
verantwortlich war nicht alleine dabei
aber ich habe mich auch nie vor dieser
verantwortung gedrückt und genau der
unterschied besteht jetzt darin dass
nicht mehr alles was von belang in
diesem land seinem tisch vorbei kommen
und trotzdem kann ich noch etwas für das
land tun aber ich bin jetzt nicht
verpflichtet mich zu jedem punkt der
irgendwie aufkommt ob das neuen euro
ticket gutes oder schlecht und ob dies
oder jenes gut ist und ob die
vieles hat mit meiner nein viele
mit meiner natürlich hat vieles eine
vorgeschichte und weil das jetzt auch
noch sehr frisch ist dass sie aus dem
markt raus bin bin ich natürlich für
vieles noch mitverantwortlich aber
das ganz klar ich möchte dinge tun und
ich bin politikerin immer aus
leidenschaft gewesen deshalb werde ich
auch nicht verkriechen und dass die
sechs monate ich habe ja vorher gesagt
was ich tue das ich mir erstmal mich
erhole und abstand gewinnen und das dann
so getan wurde als seien aus angst vor
den data ereignissen irgendwie
verschwunden und wahrscheinlich würde
auch nie wiederkommen ich finde ein
halbes jahr ist jetzt bei 16 jahre
kanzlerschaft und 30 jahren politik nun
nicht unermesslich lang
ich kann darauf
weil sie waren jetzt in den
florenz rom urlaub und andrej melik der
ukrainische botschafter in berlin hat
sinngemäß will ich jetzt mal sagen so
weder weniger getwittert dass sie lieber
nach botschaft fahren sollten als sich
die sonne italiens ins gesicht scheinen
zu lassen steht man dann eigentlich
immer sozusagen jeder bewegung neben
diesen
fernsehbildern oder was denken sie in
dem moment da wird wenn sie so wenn man
sieht dass ich koche ich bin jetzt nicht
die überbringer dieser nachricht aber
ist nicht an mir vorbeigegangen
ich muss ihnen erstmal sagen dass ich
mir auch ein bisschen ich kann es mir
eigentlich nicht richtig vorstellen aber
ein bisschen kann ich wie es einem
präsidenten der ukraine wurde unter mir
selensky geht ich kenne ihn und
ich
meine ganz am anfang haben wir nicht nur
hat ja nicht nur russland eine schwere
fehleinschätzung bezüglich des romans
von kiew gemacht sondern das angebot ja
könnte auch das land verlassen und seine
antwort ich brauche keine
mitfahrgelegenheit sondern waffen war ja
auch sehr eindeutig und hat mir auch
wirklich hochachtung eingeflößt muss ich
sagen und das macht zum beispiel auch
den unterschied aus zu einer ukraine wie
sie vielleicht spekulativ aber vor
jahren noch gewesen wäre und
da muss ich sagen hat
kann ich das irgendwo auch
nachvollziehen und das ist ein
unglaublicher druck und
ist es ja auch kommunikativ nicht
einfach den fokus auch immer wieder auf
diese leiden und den schrecklichen
dingen zu halten auf der anderen seite
habe ich mir natürlich ahnend dass ich
in italien irgendwo entdeckt werde er
vorher auch überlegt machst du diese
reise machte sie nicht und ich wäre
wahrscheinlich nicht irgendwo in die
südsee zum badeurlaub gefahren aber ich
habe mir überlegt nach 16 jahren hat
sich immer mal den wunsch auch in die
europäische geschichte ein bisschen
tiefer einzubringen wie interessiert die
renaissance weil ich sie einfach dann
später für die aufklärung und für unsere
demokratie für unerlässlich halte ich
habe mir den david angeschaut von
migranten der vielleicht auch ein
beispiel für seinen mut ist wie jetzt
gerade in der ukraine ist und ich habe
mir gedacht das machst du wissen dass
das vielleicht auch diskussionen und
ärger gibt aber auch versuchen klar zu
machen dass ich jetzt eben nicht mehr
die bundeskanzlerin bin sondern
dass ich außer diensten bin also nicht
pflicht versäumen und denn ich muss ja
auch noch mal ich kann ja jetzt ich
finde den rest meines lebens was immer
auf der welt passiert
nicht mehr verreisen dürfen und nur noch
in die uckermark gehen
diese reise war mir sehr wichtig weil
ich durch so viele ausstellungen
gerutscht bin und durch so viele sachen
mir nicht in ruhe angucken konnte all
die jahre überall gewesen bin und doch
nicht gewesen bin dass ich einfach das
für mich wollte das war für meinen für
meinen sozusagen abkopplung prozess von
der politik einfach auch individuell
wichtigsten haben sie dann so
länder
sind die sie kann auch richtig so ziel
sein in diese fragen wollen die ist
dieser traum ländern die sie verreisen
wollen ich habe so viel tolles gesehen
ich
hab viele länder reisen wollte und würde
mal wollte ich noch zu amtszeiten nach
bhutan
weil die dort diesen well-being also
einen glücksindex haben man habe
festgestellt dass wir gar keine
diplomatischen beziehungen mit gut
aber das mag jetzt nicht an uns sondern
das lag am brutal weil die ganz so klein
sind gar nicht so viel kraft haben mit
180 länder auf der welt diplomatische
beziehung zusammen ich habe das dann
verworfen weil es mir wahrscheinlich als
urlaubsreise ausgelegt worden wäre aber
ich könnte mir sehr sehr viele dinge
vorstellen ich meine ich war punktuell
immer nur sehr kurz in indien in jedem
kontinent
früher wollte ich noch mit der
transsibirischen eisenbahn auch durch
russland fahren das übrig sich jetzt
aber
einmal durch die rocky mountains sie
hatten ja das glück deshalb habe ich sie
da auch die stunde reden lassen
um der wahrheit die ehre zu geben zu der
geschichte wollte ich folgendes sagen
ich hab mich schon gewundert dass sie
die ganze stunde geredet haben
dann aufgestanden habe gesagt die stunde
ist vorbei wir haben aber einen zweiten
termin vereinbart was ich sonst fast nie
noch das heißt also der zweite termin
hat auch stattgefunden habe ich muss
nicht reden aber die panther war so
besser sie sind kichernd auf gestand mit
frau christiansen und hab ich da sitzen
lassen diese sind über frauen in uns
eine stunde und zwar von hannover soll
ja auch immer sehr gerne bin können auf
eine nochmalig gesessen habe hab nur
gedacht auch von hannover kommt man
irgendwann in berlin an und dann ist
übrigens hat mir haben sie manchmal
getroffen andere ideen den botschafter
ich habe ihn natürlich band jetzt wo er
im laufe der nicht jetzt wahrscheinlich
vorher natürlichkeit hoffen also als
präsident insgesamt letzten besuch in
berlin gemacht hat und auch wenn ich in
der ukraine war bayern natürlich dabei
er hat nämlich heute morgen
eine sms geschickt und hat mir
gratuliert zu sehr große chance mit
ihnen besprechen zugang
und und dann hab ich ging habe ich
zurückgeschrieben da bis auf vielen dank
schicken sie doch mal eine frage
die sie interessieren oder die der
bundeskanzlerin stelle er hat 4
geschickt
also ich sag dir mal ein und zwar im
prinzip gehen die alle in dieselbe
richtung
dass sie
mit nicht nur sie
aber auch sie mit mit der politik wie er
sagt die
die tore überhaupt sozusagen diesen
angriff überhaupt erst möglich gemacht
haben
und wie sie das sehen ob sie dazu
stellung nehmen würden ja ist das ist
nicht meine meinung ich glaube wenn im
jahr
2014 oder dann anfang 2015 als wir dass
es mindestens zwei abkommen gemacht
haben nichts passiert wäre hätte putin
riesenschaden in der ukraine anrichten
können und
diese sieben jahre waren für die
entwicklung der ukraine ganz ganz
wichtig es ist trotzdem zu diesem
schrecklichen zu dieser schrecklichen
situation gekommen aber ich halte das
nicht für richtig und 2008 ist meine
einschätzung die braucht man nicht zu
teilnahme meiner einschätzung ganz klar
wenn damals dieser membership action
plan gekommen wäre wäre es noch
schneller gegangen damals war die pläne
noch weiter davon entfernt
dass sie diesen
widerstand hätte leisten können den sie
heute leisten kann
es wirkt immer so als würden würde man
eine entschuldigung von ihnen etwa
erwarten für was auch immer
alle mit denen ich werde sie sagen immer
dass jedoch sehr
eigentlich immer als eine der wenigen
relativ deutlich gemacht haben sowohl in
china als auch russland
was sie von putin halten ihn kritisiert
haben
die frage ist wenn sie sich ins können
sich politiker wenn sie sich
entschuldigen müssten sie haben vorhin
organisieren was bleibt man anders
machen können gäbe es eine art von
entschuldigung für diesen teil nicht für
die osterhuber habe ich mich ein schöner
rabbi um entschuldigung gebeten aber wie
bitte die usa kann man doch ich habe
mich so als hätte ich ja nicht um mein
studium gebeten naja aber jetzt zu zum
zum ernst der lage zu ich glaube
erstens ist mir diesen wochen jetzt noch
mal ganz klar geworden was wir in
deutschland für ein glück hatten und in
ganz europa das 1989 90 so abgelaufen
ist wie es abgelaufen ist denn wenn
ja also ich meine gorbatschow war
kommunist der wahl
der kpd su da gibt es jetzt auch er hat
bald die kommen wahrscheinlich auch
durchaus schuld auf sich geladen aber
wir haben einfach einen sehr guten
moment der geschichte
abgepasst und es gab ja vorher auch
viele sehr schwierige momente kalten
krieg war es ja auch so ich meine als
das kriegsrecht in polen ausgerufen
wurde als die russen in die sowjetunion
in 1968 bei doccheck einmarschiert ist
da war kalter krieg da konnte dem land
nicht geholfen werden und dann musste
man durch und dass wir dann das noch
erleben durften in diesem fall haben
beide das ist ein großes glück und
danach hat sich die weltlage doch wieder
verdüstert
und die dinge laufen nicht mehr so
einfach ich habe damals mit angehaltenem
atem da gesessen als herkules geschafft
hatte dass wir mitglied der nato werden
konnten habe dass für alles andere als
selbstverständlich gehalten ich habe
angehalten arten gesessen dass diese
600.000 russischen sowjetischen soldaten
abgezogen sind
und
so und jetzt habe ich versucht in die
richtung zu arbeiten das unheil
verhindert wird und diplomatie ist ja
nicht wenn sie nicht gelingt deshalb
falsch gewesen also ich sehe nicht dass
ich mich da jetzt sagen müsste das war
falsch und
werde deshalb auch mich nicht
entschuldigen und ich weiß auch nicht
was gewonnen worden wäre wenn putin
einfach 2014 weiter gemacht hätte und
sich keiner darum gekümmert hätte also
an 6000 leute in den ball zu besitzen
wir heute noch im nacken sage ich ganz
offen und ich habe mich ja zu keiner
zeit der illusion hingegeben man hört
immer gesagt wir hätten alle an wandel
durch handel geglaubt ich habe dich
dahin geglaubt dass putin durch handel
gewandelt wird
sondern ich habe geglaubt dass der
nachbarschaft zu russland und europa und
russland sind nachbarn wenn es schon
politisch nicht geht wenn ich es
bestimmte handelsbeziehungen sinnvoll
sind weil man sich nicht vollkommen
ignorieren kann es wird man auch in der
zukunft nicht können und
das was für die ukraine jetzt so
tragisch ist dass sie natürlich
hier wird das unendlich viel schwerer
als uns gemacht den weg zu gehen den sie
selbstbestimmt gehen möchte und sie
erlebt im grunde so etwas was eben polen
und die
56 und 53 bei uns und 68 in prag was was
andere auch erlebt haben und jetzt bist
du das doch unsere aufgabe zu versuchen
das so wenig wie möglich
stattfinden zu lassen und letztlich ist
die ukraine auch geopolitische geisel
des westens putins hass putins
ja man muss sagen fall schafft geht
gegen das westliche demokratische modell
und er hat und da war ich ja auch nicht
blauäugig oder so ich weiß noch sehr wie
ich oft mit leuten gesagt habe ihr wisst
dass er europa zerstören will er will
die europäische union zerstören weil er
sie als vorstufe zur nato sieht aber
jetzt kann ich ja nicht so tun als gäbe
es ihn nicht und bevor jetzt man sofort
anfängt krieg zu führen gegen russland
hat man die pflicht und schuldigkeit
diplomatisch alles zu versuchen und ich
wüsste nicht was wir preisgegeben haben
im gegenteil ich habe alle halbe jahre
musste im europäischen rat darüber
diskutiert werden ob er die sanktionen
verlängern und wie viele leute habe ich
erlebt wie gesagt haben macht doch
endlich weiter und so weiter und so fort
wir haben sie immer verlängert und meine
dinge hätten auch die grimms aktionen
schärfer ausfallen können nur was wir
jetzt gelernt haben ist ja viel über
nostrum 2 gesprochen worden was wir
gelernt haben ist
putin hat der ukraine angegriffen obwohl
in ostritz war noch gar nicht im betrieb
verehrt also nicht gewartet sondern dass
dieses geopolitische ziel zu verhindern
dass vor seiner haustür ein land sich
für ein anderes modell was er als
westlich beeinflusst beschreibt was ich
natürlich vollkommen anders sehe das hat
ihnen dazu gebracht jetzt auch seinem
volk der riesige opfer aufzubauen
aber haben sie in dieser sozusagen der
beschreibt es ist ja sozusagen viele
leute steigen hier sozusagen in putin
sprechen versuchen ihn zu erklären
sozusagen erst krank erster oder zweiter
in ihrer in ihrer erklärung jetzt liegt
ja immer noch eine gewisse logik ist ja
selbst in diesem wahnsinn behalten sie
in vier bereichen machen na ja es lohnt
sich zumindest genau hinzuhören da sind
wir uns glaube ich in alle einig und ich
sage ich sehe eine kontinuierliche linie
bei der immer mehr grenzüberschreitung
gemacht hat und wo ja jetzt die
politische diskussion ist hätte man bei
der annexion der krim härter politisch
rangehen müssen das war damals nicht
mehr als fähig aber diese haben ja auch
nicht nichts gemacht er ist damals aus
g8 ausgeschlossen worden wir haben
damals auf dem
gipfel dann in wales das zwei prozent
ziel für die nato festgelegt und ehrlich
gesagt wo ich mich manchmal als auch ein
bisschen wundere ist die cdu und csu
waren eigentlich die einzigen die in
ihre regierungsprogramme dieses 2
prozent ziehen auch eingeschrieben haben
und ich habe viele stunden meines lebens
damit verbracht zwischen 2005 14 und 17
nahezubringen meinem koalitionspartner
dass wir eine bewaffnete drohnen
brauchen
die sich zwischen 2040 ab 50 schon aber
dann bis 21 im grunde es ist mir nicht
gelungen ich bin jetzt heilfroh dass wir
nun uns endlich auch entscheiden nachdem
die ganze welt bewaffnete drohnen hat
dass wir auch welche kaufen und es ist
auch nicht an mir gescheitert dass
bestimmte andere dinge nicht stattfinden
konnte es waren sehr zäh es ging
überhaupt die militärische abschreckung
zu investieren und wenn sie mich fragen
was hätten wir vielleicht stärker machen
sollen ich möchte dass die einzige
sprache die putins versteht das muss man
schon sagen dass er gesehen hat dass wir
an der stelle und nicht nur deutschland
sondern viele andere auch eben nicht
mehr die schlagkraft des kalten krieges
hatten und deshalb halte ich auch in
afghanistan für so bedauerlich weil er
da gesehen hat dass im grunde jetzt
dasselbe passiert ist was mit der
sowjetunion auch passiert ist das hat
ihnen natürlich wahrscheinlich er mit
genugtuung erfüllt aber ich finde auch
mal darauf hinweisen dass wir von 2014
dann nach dem 15 bales den bundeswehr
etat von 2 30 auf 50 milliarden
erhöht haben also so viel wie nie also
ist man kann nicht sagen wir haben auf
die krim alexion überhaupt nicht
reagiert ja aber die bundeswehr muss
sich jetzt als spieler dann sagen es
schon schon ziemlich verlottert unter
ihrer unter ihrer ägide was man so sagen
oder
als ob sie von dort hatte man jetzt
sagen ich habe also erst mir wer ist der
wehr eta haben sie gedient
[Musik]
selbstverständlich befreien
ok ja ich weiß also über soldaten
zuspricht das tut mir jetzt ein bisschen
wie also erstens habe ich mir jetzt
angeschaut als ich aus dem amt gegangen
bin war der bundeswehr etat so hoch wie
der von frankreich und großbritannien
ungefähr und dass man dann einfach sagt
da ist gar nichts eigentlich so dann
muss man vielleicht auch die frage
stellen und die muss ich mir natürlich
auch stellen hat man genug druck gemacht
um das beschaffungswesen damals zu
verändern aber da will ich nochmal sagen
jede 25 millionen ausgabe wusste durch
eine haushaltsausschuss das also müssen
sich alle ein bisschen an die nase
fassen da fasse ich mir mit an die nase
aber die bundeswehr hat es gilt im
ausland wenn sie generalsekretär der
nato fragen stoltenberg der spricht sehr
gut über die bundeswehr wir waren
diejenigen die in afghanistan die ganze
zeit dabei waren wir haben 20 nationen
mit geführt wir haben
wir haben eine sehr sehr gute reputation
bei unseren anderen auslandseinsätzen
und insofern kann ich das so nicht sagen
wir sind viel stellen nicht ausreichend
ausgerüstet aber ich will man auch sagen
auch selbst in der ganzen nato ist man
ja in der zeit doch davon ausgegangen
dass wir jetzt einer friedlichen ordnung
in der welt entgegen gehen und dass die
eigene verteidigung des nato gebietes
war jahrelang nicht die hauptaufgabe wir
haben dann erst wales wieder reaktion
auf die krim die ostflanke gestärkt bis
dahin war da so gut wie gar nichts auf
grundlage der nato russland akte von
1997 und ja man kann immer noch mehr
machen aber die bundeswehr hat
nachholbedarf darauf können wir uns
einigen das anderen worten wichtig für
mich nicht in monieren dass wir uns
schwer auszusprechen
der soldat habe
aber ich war nicht nur
soldaten sondern
war auch mit hat man reportage über
einen ein oberst aus thüringen der sein
regiment
vorbereiten musste auf einen einsatz in
afghanistan
den wird extrem schwer gefallen ist weil
er den eindruck hatte dass sie eine
an einem einsatz beteiligt sind ja
eigentlich
nicht mehr richtig gebäudes von der
politik der 1000 sozusagen musste der in
seinem
dienstzimmer die die bilder der
bundespräsidentin damals sogar wulff
abhängig dass jacko verhängt aber noch
nicht da und so in berlin ähnlich werde
bei den die armee wurde zu einer
berufsarmee gemacht und sie hatten
sowohl schwierigkeiten
sich zu motivieren für diesen einsatz
auf dem ganzen ein gefährlicher einsatz
vieler soldaten gefallen
als auch sie hatten den einmal gehört
der findet zu im luftleeren raum statt
also so ganz einfach das ist doch ich
nicht
afghanistan entdeckten die haare jetzt
also etwa musste ich jetzt mal in meiner
karriere sagte 17 uhr genauer 2010 es
war ja sitzen ja ja es war natürlich
schon auch frustriert dass er klar ich
meine schon es
war überhaupt erst mal der schwerste
einsatz und im rückblick gesprochen
sondern man kann ja viel an karl theodor
zu guttenberg kritisieren aber dass er
das wort krieg damals in den mund
genommen hat das war schon richtig und
hat den soldaten glaube ich auch gut
getan weil es jetzt endlich mal die
dimensionen klar wurde so zweitens ist
sind die afghanistan-soldaten
eigentlich immer noch recht gut
ausgerüstet gewesen aber sie haben dann
auch wieder gewusst dass ihr dann lücken
reißen woanders das hat sie vielleicht
auch nicht motiviert dass wir politisch
das nicht begleitet haben würde ich so
nicht sehen sondern wir haben ja immer
wieder versucht
vielleicht haben wir sie haben dass die
stelle ja auch vorgelesen damals hat
joschka fischer mit bestem wissen und
gewissen auf dem petersberg ein
gesellschaftsmodell für afghanistan
entworfen die taliban war nicht dabei
und sie haben im grunde dann der ganzen
sache den stempel aufgedrückt und die
mutwilligen in afghanistan immer wieder
zu sagen zurückgedrängt und deshalb habe
ich gesagt vielleicht müssen wir unsere
pläne etwas realistischer kleiner machen
und es gab ja weg ist
steinig tonnen fasst dafür dass er
gesagt hat wir müssen die taliban reden
ich habe ihn damals auch nicht
verteidigt aber letztlich ja wenn man
mit den leuten nicht redet ist ist es
auch immer schlecht also darüber muss
man schon diskutieren
dennoch sage ich mal hab ich mir nie
eine illusion gemacht wie lange sind die
amerikaner schon in europa stationiert
gewesen und dass man jetzt so ein land
im sozusagen innerhalb von 15 jahren
befriedet ist vielleicht auch eine sehr
ambitioniertes konzept gewesen und
deshalb bleibt natürlich jetzt auch ein
riesen schlechtes gewissen was hat man
da hinterlassen oder was haben wir da
hinterlassen und ich war immer dafür
dass weiterzumachen und war
hab schon mit obama darüber geredet und
gut zu bayern hat jetzt die entscheidung
getroffen die amerikaner waren dort die
hauptakteure insofern mussten wir uns
fügen aber
wir müssen uns bei
zukünftigen einsätzen auch darüber
rechenschaft ablegen dass manches auch
sehr viel länger dauern kann
das ist bedauerlich werden unsere
aufmerksamkeit spanne reicht im moment
gar nicht mehr afghanistan wie im moment
wir gucken sie reicht ja immer mehr oder
weniger nur für ein großer ereignissen
das ist ja auch ein bisschen der zug der
zeit ich meine ich habe jetzt noch mal
gelesen wenn man das so sieht in einem
buch über mich da steht 2013
bundestagswahl und dann geht es los mit
der ukraine janukowitsch will das
assoziierungsabkommen nicht
unterschreibt ja auch
die nicht auf dem schirm gehabt was hat
die denn die ganze zeit gemacht auch ja
sie hat er vielleicht
koalitionsverhandlungen geführt so und
dann bekam aber gerade aus der
weltwirtschaftskrise wie man in der
euro-krise wir
und als ich dann sozusagen aber
griechenland und als die ukraine war
januar
februar 2014 und dann hat sie lange
gedauert kamen die vielen flüchtlinge
und so
sind ja auch immer viele themen zu
beackern aber und noch ein wort zur
wehrpflicht das war damals also es war
damals vielleicht falsch dass man an der
bundeswehr so viel
gestrichen hat das haben wir später ab
2014 wieder gutgemacht die wehrpflicht
abzuschaffen unterm strich stehe ich
heute noch dazu ich habe die generäle
also die befehlshaber der verschiedenen
teilstreitkräfte alle gefragt im abstand
halten sie es für richtig oder falsch
und alle haben gesagt mit der heutigen
technisch sehr hoch gerüsteten oder
ausgerüstete bundeswehr ist die
abschaffung der wehrpflicht für sie eine
hilfe ich würde gerne noch mal
zurückkommen
wegen der aufmerksamkeitsspanne auch zu
putin er hat
und zu ihrem verhältnis zu putin sie
haben ja wirklich sehr oft und sehr
lange
getroffen und es gibt schon noch
parallelen zwischen den beinen sind etwa
sind natürlich deutlich jünger als
protein und
wieviel zwei jahre ja
in unserem alter kann ist auf jedes jahr
und
aber sie haben im prinzip beide die
erfahrung dass sie in einer diktatur
aufgewachsen sind sie haben den beide
die erfahrung dass sie dass sie den
zusammenbruch mit mutter ganz anderen
vorzeichen natürlich diese dieser dieses
systems erlebt haben mit ganzen
anschlüssen vermutlich mehr aber sie
da sie sprechen die sprache sie sprechen
russisch spricht deutsch interessieren
sich für die russische kultur er
vermutlich denkt man für die deutsche
gehörten mit den gemeinsamkeiten aber
können sie ihnen
können sie ihn erklären darum geht es
doch nicht ich glaube dass in der
politik dass in der politik das ist so
eine konstellation gewesen ja aber es
geht nicht darum etwas zu erklären
sondern ich war bundeskanzlerin der
bundesrepublik deutschland ich habe ein
bestimmtes werteverständnis und dieses
werteverständnis ist grundsätzlich
unterschiedlich von dem von
präsident putin er hält die demokratie
und da gibt es ja viele und lange
aufsätze auch über das ganze russische
system und so weiter er hält sie für
falsch ich halte sie für richtig und ich
halte sie für die menschlichste ordnung
bei all ihren fehlbarkeit 2
ist für mich aber
politik nicht nur werte sondern auch
immer interessen meines landes und das
interesse des landes dass ich regiert
habe ist im grundsatz mit russland ein
modus vivendi zu finden indem wir nicht
im kriegszustand sind sondern indem wir
versuchen können bei allen differenzen
irgendwo existieren
da man sich die
dafür dafür haben wir zu arbeiten und
das ist unser interesse und deshalb
unterstützen wir jetzt ja auch die
ukraine bei der ukraine ist teil des
problems was der gesamte westen mit
putin hat und deshalb war mein herz bei
dem ganzen normandie format nicht
irgendwie aufgeteilt hat putin und halb
selensky oder poroschenko sein herz hat
immer für die ukraine geschlagen aber
ich hab mir versucht auch die
kräfteverhältnisse vorzustellen und zu
sagen wir müssen auch die realität mit
ins blickfeld nehmen
und als ich neulich auch in der ukraine
der außenminister kollegen zum beispiel
hat ja neulich auch gesagt die frage was
ist ein sieg jetzt wird diskutiert was
ist ein sieg was ist ein siegel er
gesagt fragen was ist ein sieg
entwickelt sich im laufe der zeit auch
noch mal und ich möchte dass die ukraine
die möglichst gut rauskommt und so
wollte ich es immer und deshalb gibt es
da kein verstehen und wenn ich jetzt
mich so zurück erinnere dann würde ich
sagen vor der annexion der krim gab es
immer noch
[Musik]
ereignisse man hat sie mal
persönlichen geschenk gegeben oder
irgendetwas
nachdem die alexander grimm war war
schon ein tiefer einschnitt also wir
haben sozusagen
beziehung gepflegt wie sie die pflichten
von staats- und regierungschefs sind
aber für mich war es dann vollkommen
klar dass wir es hier nicht mit jemandem
zu tun haben der uns wohlergehen wünscht
nach unserer art zu nehmen trotzdem kann
ich ihn nicht aus der welt schaffen und
russlands ist eine größe und wenn
russland sich jetzt mit china total
zusammen tut ob das jetzt alles besser
wird für uns wir müssen ja auch immer
gucken was können wir denn leisten wie
stark sind wir und jetzt ist es ganz
ganz wichtig dass die europäische union
zusammen hält das davon kann ich ein
lied sing nichts wäre schlimmer gewesen
wenn wir diese aktionen gemacht hätten
damals peter grimm wo die eine hälfte
der europäischen union jahr gesagt hatte
die andere hälfte hinein gesagt und so
aber es ist schon eine sehr rationale
beziehung wo es richtig um ein
wettbewerb von
gesellschaftspolitischen vorstellungen
gibt ja aber mit zwei personen und
vielleicht ist sozusagen der boulevard
schon dass du mir der der da der darauf
herumreitet sie haben es vorhin
angesprochen das war fordert also zwei
sachen und mich noch etwas hin zu putins
und damit den druck durch die eine ist
der hund ist die es gibt ja verschiedene
texte werden jetzt gerne auch
illustriert immer mit dem hund
[Musik]
um sie sind vom hund mal gewissen worden
er wollte sie damit ein schüchtern ist
so soll das heißen bad oder hat mir hat
irgendjemand jetzt gerade erzählt
daß das labrador hunde war und das ist
ja vorher gefragt hat dass er irgendwo
möglich sogar eine freude machen wollte
naja
wers glaubt wird selig also mein erster
besuch im kreml der lag vor dem search
besuch war so dass putin schon zu mir
gesagt hat ich habe gehört war es ein
problem mit hund und da hatte so einen
großen stoff und für mich und insofern
konnte ich also den hund ins vollständig
als liebevoll hinzufallen grad und ich
fragt hund so einfach hier ist keine
frage bekannt geworden vielleicht haben
meine leute sich nicht getraut kann ich
mir nicht vorstellen kann mir wirklich
nicht mehr so sagen dann könnte nun sein
der tapfere bundeskanzlerin muss mit
seinem hund fertig werden
wenn solche psychologischen
schwierigkeiten dazu führen dass man
nicht mehr voll politisch handlungsfähig
ist dann ist was läuft was falsch zweite
frage
ich habe gelesen in einer dieser dicken
demografin über sie dass sie
nach der annexion als die sagt der
verhältniswahl anders sehr viel mit
obama telefoniert haben aber auch
unfassbar hier mit putin und dass sie da
gebrüllt haben von beiden seiten
obama angebrüllt ddt oder war man nicht
alle englisch sie und putin und die
frage ist haben sie auf russisch geburt
oder auch deutsch ich habe daher ich
glaube sommer der brüllt hat meistens
unrecht insofern
kann ich mich doch nicht ein
[Musik]
jetzt ehrlich nicht also ich aber reden
die russisch-deutsche oder meistens
putin spricht besser deutsch als ich
russisch und insofern redet er über
ernsthafte politik sprechen redet jeder
in seiner sprache und
manchmal redet er auch deutsch und
einmal kommt es vor dass jetzt auch egal
dass er ein wort nicht wusste das wusste
ich dann auf russisch aber er redet
deutsch und ich nicht russisch mit ihm
weil das meistens auch zu ernst ist
absoluter
er hat die zweite frage sagt noch
schnell die manic also von den vieren
war wieso sie nach all der zeit die sie
mit mit putin verbrachten haben mit den
vielen gesprächen
jetzt nicht nach dem ausbruch des
krieges mit ihnen telefoniert haben um
ihnen
darum
und zu vor dass dieser das hat diese
aggression aufhört
also ehrlich gesagt
ist mein amtsverständnis so dass ich
nichts tun werde und dass mich nicht die
deutsche regierung bitten würde aber ich
auch jetzt gar nicht erwartet dass hier
irgendetwas gebeten werden das hätten
auch klar zu sagen ich das jetzt noch
rauskommen
aber
ganz wichtig ist also wir hatten zum
beispiel mal die situation dass im
zusammenhang mit der liste shell wir
gerd schröder bitten wollte hat gabriel
als außenminister mit ihm gesprochen und
dann hat schröder gesagt das mache ich
aber nur wenn auch die kanzlerin mich
darum bittet und das ist das normale
verhalten so punkt 1.2 habe ich nicht
den eindruck dass sagen ja auch kanzler
scholz und und präsident mag und putin
und andere ich habe den eindruck dass
das im augenblick etwas nützt
sondern putin hat eine entscheidung
getroffen die halte ich für
katastrophe als fatal auch blick auf
russland für sehr sehr fehlerbehaftet
aber das jetzt egal und deshalb gibt es
aus meiner sicht auch immer mit wenig zu
besprechen und schon gar nicht ohne mit
der ukraine zu sprechen und aus der
ukraine hat mich auch kein wunsch
erreicht insofern finde ich die frage
wenn sie denn so gestellt wurde bist du
geschützt das ist ja okay dann die
anderen beiden stelle ich höre immer zu
wenn mir was will aber solche sachen
macht man öffentlich interessant ist
sozusagen für mich zumindest interessant
dass ihr verhältnis überhaupt zum
russischen ansicht also sie das erstmals
sprechen dass sie
ja
ein pastoralkolleg des vaters gab es
auch von unserer schule ziehen sie haben
er sich ja in der schule auch schon oft
gelesen mit marta wahrscheinliche
vermute mal
bergauf bulgakow haben sie meistern
marita vermutlich und sie haben ihren
kollegen schindhelm damals der akademie
verleast und ende der 80er jahre gold
geschenkt sie fordern sehen und haben
uns eingeschrieben gehens offene
hat mir was rein geschrieben daher hat
ihn was er hat mir gesagt geschrieben
oder aber auf jeden fall gibt aber gott
jetzt bin ich durcheinander vielleicht
haben sie recht
angestellt das ist ja extrem lange
auf den bergen auch ein richtiger hat
mich gehört zu den nagel und ist auf ja
ja da wollte ich später läuft sozusagen
die zeit lang war leider überhaupt nicht
mehr
arbeiten und zu leben zu dem russischen
was sie haben ja auch sozusagen das als
junge frau dann mal durch durch die
kaukasus getrennt das sind noch
sozusagen die bremische und georgische
und sowjet republik war kläger muss man
sagen aber sie sagen sie eigentlich
heißt egal oder die plätze na ja heute
sagt man tiflis aber ich habe natürlich
dann im artistik gesagt na ja das war
damals vielleicht für die die aus den
alten bundesländern kommen es war damals
man dort zusammen 17 lebensjahr und eine
ein jahr nach polen und ein jahr nach
bratislava prag und budapest und
bukarest und sofia und dann irgendwo die
gebirge und wenn man 27 war oder so dann
hat man das alles einfach so oft gemacht
und mehr gab es nicht und dann gab es
eine halblegale methode man durfte
nämlich zwei tage transitvisum durch die
sowjetunion nach bulgarien oder rumänien
reisen und das war
unglaublich attraktiv weil kaum hatte
man die russische an der russischen
föderation kam er gar nicht vorbei mahnt
vor durch die ukraine dann doch doch
dann kurz vom kaukasus steht man da in
aus und hatte aber im grunde nur wenige
kilometer haben war man in georgien oder
brasilien wie man damals sagte und die
fanden alles schon das war damals eine
sehr interessante entdeckung
aserbaidschan armenien und cousinen
georgien kann damals schon dass das weh
ja nun gar nicht geht dass man da nur
wenige stunden in diesen republiken ist
brust doch da so schön ist und dann
konnte man aber keine fahrkarte kaufen
musste zelten und so weiter so und dann
hatte ich mich da mit zwei anderen 14
tage aufgehalten und zum schluss bin ich
noch gut herausgekommen weil ich in
sotschi ein am flughafen einen aufsatz
schreiben musste warum habe ich studiert
und mich trotzdem nicht an die gesetze
gehalten
und sollte eine größere rubel menge
dafür ausgegeben werden und nach ich
kann ihn aus dass auf russisch schreiben
ich brauche hier nicht zu bezahlen und
dann bin ich noch am gleichen tag
weggekommen nach berlin-schönefeld was
ja heute wieder unser großer airport ist
wer hätte das gedacht
aber können sie dann in miami in einem
satz vielleicht sagen oder das damals
war schon klar in den drei republiken
moskaus weit nicht
also leute sagt mir nach der ddr
propaganda nicht vorstellen können dass
so eine kulturelle distanz bestand und
das war vollkommen klar
und trotzdem gibt es eine faszination
offenbar für rosa tour für das land die
weiters landes die schönheit des landes
und so weit haben sie
bekommt daher kann man die beschreiben
und wenn die kommt natürlich schauen sie
wenn ich in westdeutschland aufgewachsen
wäre ich habe auch die faszination für
amerika und ich hätte dann als erstes
englisch gelernt und hätte mich da auch
ausdrücken können und so trotzdem halte
ich russland für einen als solches
faszinierendes land und
ich faszinierend glaube ich auch länder
die so weit sind also die seitlichen
stadt war amerika sind ja auch diese
diese große weite und bei sibirien dass
das natürlich noch mal was ganz anderes
und jetzt nochmal sagen auch russland
wir wir sind ja nicht unabhängig
voneinander wir haben jetzt das
dramatische problem mit mit der ukraine
aber wir haben das iranische atom-
abkommen russland die permafrostböden
sind viele jahr wieder mit putin auch
darüber gesprochen über den klimawandel
und er war viele jahre ziemlich ignorant
bis dann die
permafrostböden
zu schnell also was auf zutrauen
beginnen jetzt und diese permafrostböden
sind einer der größten co2 speicher
jetzt kommt gleich nachdem amazon
der gebiet und das ist das ist eine
riesenherausforderung für uns und für
die ganze menschheit und insofern
schauen sie ich kann das schon sehr gut
unterscheiden zwischen der faszination
für dieses land aber das was die politik
in diesem land zurzeit macht ist warum
nicht ab ist verstehe ich weiß was ich
meine ist
haben sie manchmal sorge oder wie kann
man das eigentlich trennen das sozusagen
die
russische und in diesen diese furchtbare
aggression die putin ausgibt voneinander
trennt in der öffentlichen wahrnehmung
wird ja das kann man ganz einfach ich
finde dass das ist ja so als wenn man
jetzt über die nationalität vergleiche
machen aber
ich kann doch die kultur eines landes in
ordnung finde ich kann sagen ich freue
mich dass gorbatschow uns die deutsche
einheit ermöglicht hat und trotzdem habe
ich jetzt jemanden der bricht das
völkerrecht und trump ist es mit füßen
und berichtes und bleibt seinem volk
riesen leiten zu und seinem eigenen volk
im übrigen auch noch denn da sterben ja
auch viele viele soldaten und die mütter
die muss man ja auch manchmal denken und
insofern
kann man das trennen und die tragik wird
eigentlich größer dadurch dass sich das
land auch mag aber nicht nachsichtiger
mir hat mal jemand erzählt ihr dabei war
dass sie vor ein paar jahren abendessen
hatten bolide tepco da war bei ihnen zu
hause die frage ist ja würden sie die
netrebko
morgen einladen zum essen nein
würde ich nicht
sie hat dann also ich sag mal ich mich
recht erinnere war sie irgendwann meinen
südossetien oder abchasien oder so also
ist eine politisch hat sie schon dinge
gemacht die ich absolut vorurteile aber
eine andere russische opernsängerin die
politische unbedenklich da hat uns das
noch mal ganz klar zu sagen ich glaube
nicht dass der jetzt in verbot von
russischer kultur machen sollten es gibt
menschen die in russland viel in die
waagschale werfen und mutig sind viel
mutiger als uns das was kostet die jetzt
versuchen leider nicht vielleicht aus
unserer sicht zu wenige aber viele die
ihr wort machen und viele die auch ihr
land verlassen mussten und ich finde wir
sollten gucken wer unterstützt das was
putin machen will und wer unterstützt
das nicht aber wenn das nicht
unterstützt auch nicht bei der russe ist
jetzt irgendwie schlecht behandelt
werden das halte ich für richtig
ihre heimat und und müssen aus ihrer
heimat weg das ist ja nicht das ja auch
schwierig und ich habe allerhöchste
hochachtung vor all denen die sich
diesem system wieder setzen das ist ja
in den letzten jahren noch immer
perfider geworden was damit jedem
passiert ja anders denkt und insofern
geht es immer um den einzelnen menschen
und ich kann nicht alle unter einem
system zu mir
überrascht sie die sagen wir die
emotionale anteilnahme der deutschen
doch also wenn man jetzt nach der aktion
zum beispiel waren 98 prozent
gewinnt 8 1989 prozent
gegen waffenlieferungen inzwischen
haben sich da die hat sich das komplett
verschoben
[Musik]
sind sieben jahre im letzten jahr waren
sie noch in der ukraine wegen wegen der
kohlenstoff sie waren sie haben
biden besucht wegen nord stream zwei es
schien alles irgendwie
geregelt zu sein herz offenbar sein okay
gegeben
und innerhalb kürzester zeit
gibt so ein wahnsinn dafür bringt das
größte verbrechen der mensch aber dessen
da passiert naja es gibt ja immer um den
umschlag von quantität in qualität das
haben wir alle gelernt und jetzt ist ein
elektrisches gesetz na ja und jetzt ist
eine sommer muss eine neue qualität
entstanden ich sage zäsur anderen neben
andere worte dafür ich will übrigens ein
wort zu präsident beiden sagen ich habe
mich im zusammenhang mit austrian sehr
geärgert
auch wenn man politisch
unterschiedlicher meinung ist präsident
biden war ja der meinung und viele
amerikaner dass im 21
dass die amerikaner ist einfach so
beantwortet haben dass wir uns immer
sanktioniert haben im grunde hat man uns
als verbündete wegen einer anderen
politischen meinung wirtschaftlich sein
unsere unternehmen sanktioniert die an
diesem projekt mitgearbeitet haben was
man einfach nur kann weil der amerikaner
schon markt so wichtig ist und das hat
mich schon sehr geärgert das macht man
mit dem iran ok mit russland jetzt
absolut richtig aber dass man mit uns
gemacht hat fand ich nicht in ordnung
und wo wir gemeinsam in afghanistan
kämpfen und viele andere sachen auch
machen so und präsident biden hat etwas
ganz außergewöhnliches gemacht was sie
im alltag
sehr dankbar er hat nämlich sage okay
ich will mich mit meinen verbündeten
jetzt wieder zusammenraufen und ich
behandele ich eben nicht wie ein feind
sondern wir machen eine gemeinsame
erklärung zur neuestem 2 ist es klar ich
will das nicht es ist klar ihr seid da
aus verschiedenen gründen noch dafür und
dann haben wir eine erklärung gemacht im
sommer 21
mit der klar war und
nichts anderes stand da drin dass
erstens conditio sine qua non für lost
und zwar ist das ukraine weiter
transitland für erdgas und zweitens dass
wenn politik oder erdgas als waffe
eingesetzt wird sie jetzt was mit der
ukraine passiert ist das dann aus dem 2
zur disposition gestellt wird so und
diese vereinbarung war für mich wichtig
und dass wir die mit beiden gemacht
haben war für mich ein wirklicher
quantensprung dass wir jetzt wieder wie
verbündete miteinander reden die über
eine bestimmte fragen unterschiedliche
meinung kann jetzt komme ich zurück zu
es ist etwas passiert dass damit ist -
dass minsk abkommen ist damit geschichte
es ist etwas passiert was eben weit also
was eine vollkommen anderer qualität ist
und deshalb muss man auch vollkommen
anders reagieren und da nutzt kann man
jetzt für für die frage wie ist das
alles glaubt und was muss man tun um
daraus zu lernen vielleicht das noch mal
alles rapid- rekapitulieren aber der
jetzige zustand erfordert ein neues
herangehen damit wird russland immer
noch nicht verschwinden von der
landkarte und wir müssen gucken wir
müssen auch verstehen dass die ukraine
im wahrsten sinne des wortes nicht
allein gelassen werden kann nicht nur
wegen der waffen im übrigen um das noch
schnell zu sagen ich war gegen waffen an
die ukraine vor allen dingen auch wegen
der besonderen rolle deutschlands und
frankreichs weil wir uns um die
moderation gekümmert haben das ist eine
arbeitsteilung und es ist im übrigen das
wollte ich auch noch mal sagen nicht
ganz richtig dass wir noch nie in ein
spannungsgebiet waffen geliefert haben
erstens unterstützen der israel mit
waffen und zweitens haben wir damals je
7 unterstützt also indem wir den kurven
waffen geliefert haben auch in einen
konflikt hinein so aber egal
das kann ich ebenfalls vertreten dass
wir damals gesagt haben wir sind
wesentlich in der diplomatie tätig das
ist heute nicht mehr auf der
tagesordnung es ist eine andere zeit
kenner zum thema einer zeit die zeit
läuft so ein bisschen zweck leider total
sehr hätte gerne mit ihnen weitergeht
aber ich würde ganz gerne einen harten
schnitt machen zwar wir haben hier viel
über lästig interessiert sich ja nicht
vermächtnis und so habe ich gesagt ich
halte mich durch diese ganzen bücher
gearbeitet
und wir haben sich über ihr vermächtnis
in der welt geredet ich würde mal ganz
kurz zum schluss noch was über ein
vermächtnis in der partei in der cdu
reden ist das nicht für sie machen
sich wahnsinnig dass sie sozusagen den
mann der sie den sie 92 im prinzip jede
ganz losgeworden sind dass er nach 16
jahren
[Musik]
als untoter
kloos aus der badewanne zurückkommt und
die und die partei übernimmt fragt man
sich da nicht
was habe ich in dieser partie eigentlich
wartet eigentlich meine partei hat die
frage die ich mir sowieso immer gestört
hat bei ihnen aber haben sie mir nicht
sehr
gerne
dort spielen hell machthaber machen aber
aber ist sozusagen gibt es dann gibt es
das vermächtnis in der partei sozusagen
etwas passiert hinterlassen hat also
erstens wird wollte ich sagen ich werde
natürlich jetzt das ja auch eines meiner
projekte mit meiner büroleiterin frau
baumann zusammen ein buch zu schreiben
um mein leben noch mal zu ohren
politisch einzuordnen und wirklich dann
auch nochmal lange linien zu zeichnen
und darauf freue ich mich richtig
zweitens ich bin gerne cdu-mitglied
drittens schafft könnte ich sagen wir
müssen guter jahrgang gewesen sein märz
dich denn er wollte die nummer 1 sein
und ich wollte die nummer eins sein das
ist ja im politischen wettbewerb kommt
sowas ja vor das gab es ja auch zwischen
hillary clinton und barack obama und so
weiter und dass er jetzt das geworden
ist an der mittel entscheidet der cdu
das ist dann so und das damals weise
interessante persönlichkeiten sich
aneinander gerieben haben das
rad jetzt noch eine interessante
vorführung gefunden und
die fronten
der cdu alles gute und
hab mich über die baldige von daher
günther und und hendrik wüst jetzt auch
wirklich gefreut und trotzdem bin ich
mir am aktuellen getümmel auch nicht in
meiner partei und die entscheidungen die
heute zu treffen sind müssen dort
getroffen werden da werden sie schon
viele finden die das auch wieder
ausdiskutieren
gute glaube wir müssen es hinbekommen
diese bekannten heute sehr viel über
dieses tolle buch was ist also mein was
ist mein land reden ganze zeit haben
über dieses buch geredeten genau wissen
sie überhaupt verstanden deswegen meiner
rede zum dritten oktober der aufbau
verlag ist angetreten aber gesprochen
haben wir nicht so viel darüber ist aber
eine wirklich ein ganz tolles buch sie
sie können das kaufen im großen salon
und aus agieren lassen von der von der
von der bundeskanzlerin
kann ich ihn wirklich ans herz legen das
ist eine rede drin sozusagen die angela
merkel vor der knesset gehalten hatten
reden die die sie die gesagt und 30
jahren stark gerade die mit herz
gebrochen hat um ehrlich zu sein
gehalten hat weil
sich die ostdeutsche plötzlich gezeigt
hat nach all den jahren uns und das ist
eine sozusagen zu diesem tollen satz wir
schaffen das
er hat sich den tollen satz wir schaffen
das aus dem jahr 215 drin wirklich sehr
empfehlenswert ich hätte noch die
harvard rede übrigens rängen wo die fans
treu ich auch gehen es offenbar aber es
hat der aufbau verlag so entschieden und
da ich gar nicht drauf gekommen wäre
dass man daraus ein büchlein machen kann
aber diese rede zum dritten oktober war
wirklich sehr persönlich und vielleicht
kann man konnte ich diese rede eben auch
nur halten weil es eine meiner letzten
reden war weil ich natürlich in dieser
rede auch ein stück verletzlichkeit
gezeigt habe dass muss man sagen also
falls jemand lust hat ich sitze da noch
und unterzeichnen
täuschungen vorzubeugen habe ich nur
gesagt ich möchte ich unterzeichne
signieren uhr dieses buch und ich
schreibe auch jetzt keine widmung rein
und so weiter weil das würde mich jetzt
überfordert
ich möchte ganz zum schluss noch etwas
sagen und zwar
wir sind natürlich dankbar dass man
diesen tollen theater sein können wir
als ostdeutsche theater mit großer aus
deutscher tradition aus deutscher verlag
besser geht es eigentlich nicht
und das jahr habe ich gebeten am ende
noch diese erklärung zu verlesen sehr
gutes publikum die menschen in der
ukraine benötigen dringend unsere hilfe
das berliner ensemble sammelt spenden
für das aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
der spender hätten sie in organisationen
den betroffenen menschen in der ukraine
und in den nachbarstaaten zu
unterstützen ihnen unter anderem
unterkünfte zur verfügung zu stellen sie
mit nahrungsmitteln kleidung
medikamenten und anderen dingen des
täglichen bedarfs zu versorgen und
psychosoziale hilfe zu leisten die
kolleginnen haben dienstes stehen jetzt
im anschluss an die vorstellung mit
spendenboxen im foyer und wir freuen uns
sehr denn auch sie uns mit einer spende
helfen und ganz am schluss möchte ich
noch mal auf das blut zurück kommen
würde dass wir nicht geredet haben und
zwar aus sie haben aus ihrer rede vor
der knesset 2008 da haben sie david ben
gurion
zitiert und ich finde das ein ganz gutes
motto nach dem ganzen mist über den wir
so redet geredet haben und ein zitat
geht folgendermaßen ja nicht an wunder
glaubt der ist kein realist vielen dank
[Applaus]